les sirènes ont retenti partout en
Israël sur le coup de 11 heures ce matin
le temps de cet appel à honorer les
soldats morts au combat le pays s'est
figé dans la douleur
[Musique]
mais cette expression collective n'a pas
réussi à terme les divisions profondes
qui déchirent la société israélienne
[Musique]
c'est dans les cimetières qu'on se
réunit pour observer le Jour du Souvenir
pas cette année pour ses familles
endeuilly plutôt que de voir les tombes
des leurs comme décor des discours de
politiciens qu'il combattent depuis des
mois pour bloquer une réforme judiciaire
ils se sont retrouvés au centre de
Tel-Aviv
je pense qu'ils font preuve d'un manque
de respect envers les soldats envers les
réservistes moi-même je suis dans la
réserve et envers les héros parmi nous
qui ne pensent pas comme le gouvernement
et qui manifeste contre lui il nous
traite mal nous traite d'anarchistes de
terroristes alors si vous me traitez
comme ça toute l'année ne m'appelez pas
votre frère pour un jour seulement
[Applaudissements]
le ministre d'extrême droite de la
sécurité publique Ithamar bengwir a
ignorer la demande de plusieurs familles
de se tenir loin des cérémonies quelques
instants après son arrivée il a été pris
à partir et chahuté par certains
opposants et partisans ont échangé des
insultes des injures
c'est honteux que la gauche envoient ces
représentants ici dans les cimetières il
provoque une commotion alors que Ben
vire vient nous témoigner son respect 17
hommes
qui étaient sur place nous nous sentons
trahis nous avons l'impression que nous
commençons à vivre dans un pays qui est
de moins en moins démocratique et allant
de plus en plus vers la dictature
comme lui des centaines de milliers
d'israeliens manifestent une opposition
farouche à une réforme judiciaire
entamée par le gouvernement de Benyamin
Netanyahou le plus à droite et religieux
de l'histoire d'Israël qui célèbre ce
soir les 75 ans de son indépendance
il se débarrasse de l'indépendance
judiciaire de ceux qui surveillent le
gouvernement en s'assurant qu'il agisse
selon la loi et dans la protection des
droits il concentre les pouvoirs une
chose que les gouvernements ont
recherché à travers l'histoire
le gouvernement a été forcé de mettre
son projet de réforme sur pause pendant
qu'il cherche un compromis avec les
parties d'opposition de la colère de la
rue n'est pas apaisée pour autant
à Jérusalem le Premier ministre Benyamin
Netanyahou a voulu conjurer le sentiment
d'unité nationale qui marque d'ordinaire
et commémorations successives du
souvenir et de l'indépendance de l'État
hébreu
ensemble comme des frères nous allons
nous tenir et assurer notre indépendance
de génération en génération a-t-il dit
ensemble comme des frères nous allons
nous tenir et nous incliner en hommage
éternel à l'héroïsme de ceux qui sont
tombés à la grandeur de leurs âmes et de
leurs familles
en soirée la cérémonie du flambeau est
venue marquer le passage des
commémorations à la mémoire des disparue
au célébrations d'indépendance
du recueillement on est passé à la fête
un peu partout le drapeau israélien
d'une nation en pleine crise identitaire
fièrement brandie
ce soir à Jérusalem ce sont les
célébrations que l'on entend mais le
bruit des festivités ne serait enterré
celui des divisions profondes la Knesset
le parlement israélien reprend pour sa
session d'été en début de semaine
prochaine ici Marie-Eve Bédard
Radio-Canada Jérusalem